ich habe heute mit großem interesse wie
ich finde spektakuläre zeilen lesen 43
prozent der deutschen können sich
vorstellen dass deutschland länger auf
atomkraft setzen als das geplant ist das
ist eine spektakuläre neue zahl bisher
war es immer so dass die absolute
mehrheit der deutschen dafür was so
schnell wie möglich dieses teufelszeug
atomkraft loszuwerden jetzt gibt es da
offenbar ein umdenken und ich finde das
gibt der bevorstehenden ampelkoalition
eine historische chance sie könnte mit
dem michael fuchs dem rücken von frau
merkel rund um fukushima und nach
fukushima ein für alle mal schluss
machen und atomenergie als übergangs
energie re aktiviert wenn das ein plan
von rot gelb grün oder besser gesagt rot
grün gelb wäre wäre das seriöse
zukunftspolitik und jetzt wird man sagen
ob das machen doch die grünen auf gar
keinen fall mit das war noch im
gründungsmythos ihr einer ihrer
wichtigsten punkte bei der gründung
ihrer partei und dann muss man einmal
innehalten und noch mal in diese
wirklich interessante umfrage schauen
jeder vierte grünen wähler kann es sich
inzwischen auch vorstellen dass
kernenergie eine
mögliche form ist in die zukunft zu
gehen und das argument dieser wähler die
sagen wir denken darum ist ganz
interessant sie sagen nämlich das
überragende gut ist dass wir unsere
klimaziele erreichen in den nächsten 30
bis 50 jahren und wir haben erkannt dass
wird es mit windrädern mit solar mit
wasser und allen möglichen nicht
schaffen werden dann tun wir es doch
lieber mit kernenergie denn wenn ich
zwischen zwei dingen zu entscheiden habe
das eine sind meine ziele und das andere
ist der weg wie ich sie erreiche dann
ist klima so wichtig dass man sich jetzt
eigentlich für kernenergie entscheidung
und das finde ich ein hoch spannendes
ergebnis dieses tages und hoffe lange
und rate den koalitionären dass sie in
diese richtung denken und aufhören mit
dieser alten ideologie
krankhaftes teufelszeug und auf der
anderen seite ist es ja mehr kernkraft
ist das allein seligmachende beides ist
unsinn aber als übergangs energie ist es
jetzt fast achtung alternativlos
[Applaus]
lieber herr strunz also ich glaube dass
allen bewusst geworden ist dass die
klimakrise so furchtbar ist dass wir uns
keine denkverbote mehr leisten können
und wir haben auch keine zeit mehr
sondern wir müssen jetzt handeln und
denkverbote wäre zu sagen beschliessen
kernenergie kategorisch aus fakt ist
aber dass ja die kernenergie tatsächlich
co2 neutral ist das haben wir das
riesenproblem nach wie vor des endlagers
und wir müssen daher dann so offen sein
und zu überlegen können wir gelder in
die hand nehmen um in forschung zu
investieren an neuen kernreaktoren das
wäre dann ein weg vor uns sagt wie
schafft man es denn tatsächlich dieses
große problem des endlagers tatsächlich
zu beheben solange das nicht geklärt ist
finde ich das hoch fragwürdig wenn wir
damit die klimakrise noch schlimmer
machen weil wir dafür keine lösung also
ist klar ich habe mir bewusst formuliert
natürlich ist es nicht das allein
seligmachende weil es dieses überragende
problem der lagerung der abfälle gibt
andererseits bin ich dann auch schon ein
bisschen technologie gläubig und sehe
mit großem mit großer faszination
das ist jetzt wirklich kleinere
reaktoren gibt ich habe heute erfahren
dass daran geforscht wird akw s auf lkws
sozusagen also im wirklichen kleinformat
dann stellt sich auch die frage der
endlagerung anders und noch mal mein
plädoyer ist nicht auf atomkraft und
kernenergie zu setzen bis zum sankt
nimmerleinstag sondern bis wir den
klimazielen er sind die wir anders nicht
erreicht ich finde sogar um noch einen
drauf zu setzen und den skeptischen
blick von der grossmann noch eins zu
verschaffen ich würde sogar sagen wer
will dass wir etwas fürs klima tun jetzt
wirklich also nicht immer nur rum reden
er muss sogar atomenergie als übergangs
energie sein ich weiß dass dieser satz
total weh tut weil er in diese in dieser
aber tatsächlich einen hinterher noch
einen satz bevor heraus waren bestimmt
dagegen angehen weiß nicht aber was ich
tatsächlich schwierig finde ist dass wer
aktuell tatsächlich den atomstrom aus
frankreich importiert und realisten
fielen und die realität ist ja pervers
wenn wir sagen wir neben tatsächlich den
dreckigen atomstrom aus frankreich
importieren den treuer hierher und lehnt
es kategorisch ab also das finde ich in
der kanzlerin schnee und die sollen mal
schauen wo sie mit dem abfall angeht es
spielt überhaupt die skeptisch ich bin
jetzt ganz bei euch und das also wenn
überhaupt etwas in der deutschen politik
fehlt was mich am meisten ärgert ist
ehrlichkeit ja wir reden über wir
brauchen elektrizität brauchen wir für
elektroautos ich ja und jetzt woher
kommt die ja aus frankreich empfängt im
verbund ja und keiner redet drüber und
solange wir mit kohle kraftwerke strom
produzieren kann man noch nicht sagen
die die autoindustrie macht werbung
emissionsfrei wo ist denn das bild der
emissionsfreie da rede ich noch nicht
mal von den weiblichen leser wenn sie
ganz konkret machen gibt es verrückte
konstellationen entstehen elektroautos
an ladesäulen deren strom aus einem
kohlekraftwerk ja das ist so irre dass
man sich eigentlich gar nicht
was ich ich glaube wir leben in einer
demokratie und das ist auch die
lebendigkeit und die offenheit bedeutet
auch dass wir unbedingt alle ehrlich
sein müssen und mit ehrlich
argumentieren und diese argumentation
diese elektromobilität als als etwas
heiliges und emissionsfrei zu bezeichnen
ja das ist einfach nicht wahr verlogen
und was sie sagen ich widerspreche nicht
ich bin 100 prozent bei ihnen also
momentan werden 156 atomkraftwerke
weltweit gebaut der technologische
fortschritt im kraftbereich ist
unglaublich es gibt sogar jetzt ein neue
technologie das praktisch die alten
brennstäbe wieder verwertet werden dass
ich gar nichts mehr übrig ist und sogar
die pcc das institut für klimawandel tag
gebrauchen kann energie und ganz klar
also ich ein ganzes kapitel im buch
darüber geschrieben werden eine
renaissance der atomkraft definitiv
sehen wir eher kleineren möglich haben
sie die einzige ist der einzige
grundlastfähige
energiequelle die wir haben die
emissionslos ist wenn wir die klimaziele
erreichen wollen brauchen wir sie und
andere länder bauen wir schalten ab und
alle anderen patienten aber es wird ja
ganz ok sein ich will bei dieser die
diskussion dürfte der oft nicht unsere
aber insgesamt zu uns intellektuellen
und im glaubensbekenntnis aber ich
glaube dass wir jetzt auch im jetzt
leben und es keine pinsel wir haben
jetzt also erlebt dass etwas
unvorstellbares passiert ist die ganze
welt war lahmgelegt durch eine pandemie
wir haben in deutschland erlebt dass
noch was anderes unvorstellbares
passiert ist kleine flüsschen haben am
ende durch hochwasser hunderte von
leuten an den tod gerissen wir müssen
uns jetzt auch vorstellen können dass
wenn wir so weiter machen mit unserer
energiepolitik es blackouts geben wird
also es kommt kein strom mehr aus der
steckdose genauso unvorstellbar übrigens
genauso und wurde niemand aber es ist
genauso welche ich sehe jetzt auch schon
menschen die die werden sagen ja der
spinnt doch das passiert doch nicht das
hätte man vor zwei jahren über eine
pandemie die ausgangssperren und so was
zur folge hat auch gesagt und über
hochwasser die aus dem saal entstehen
ist dann hätte ist noch schlimmer als
und sagen es ist noch so ja und wenn es
nicht passiert dann passiert sie sich
weil wir von den vielen atom frankreich
den investoren könnte ich werde es an
der stelle war das aber normalerweise
das jetzt aber es ist die stelle wo ich
gern mein autonome wäre nämlich autonom
und selbst
das ist ein blackout kommt sondern
lediglich wann war das europäische netz
ist komplett verbunden wenn in rumäniens
licht ausgeht geht es auch bei uns aus
und marko hat vor einigen tagen gesagt
atomenergie ist die nummer eins in
frankreich wir werden weiter investieren
werden weiter bauen wir mit unserem
knapp zwei prozent co2 ausstoß können
die welt nicht retten alleine da muss
die ganze welt an einem strang ziehen
aber um atomenergie kommen wir nicht
drum vor allem der strompreis wird
steigen mit 30,5 4 cent pro
kilowattstunde das teuerste land der
welt kein land zahlt mehr für strom dann
sahen wir bald 60 cent dann haben wir da
draußen aber auch noch eine größere
spaltung der gesellschaft sehen sie das
denn jetzt das
ihre entscheidung die
frauenstimme
überhaupt nicht also ich finde die
diskussion ja spannend und auch richtig
noch mal ich bin total gegen denkverbote
werden gerade wenn es um rettung des
klimas geht müssen wir das offen machen
nur gerade vor dem hintergrund dürfen
wir auch nicht zu schmal denken sondern
ich finde gerade auch in deutschland
haben wir noch ganz viel platz was das
thema wasserstoff technologien angeht
wir haben noch ganz viel platz auch beim
thema solar auch beim thema wind ja wir
haben schon ganz viel gemacht sie kennen
bestimmt noch früher die fahrt in urlaub
und man konnte kilometer weit gucken
heute geht es nicht mehr man ist so
gefühlt bei jeder windmühle hört man
auch so alle 300 meter
hüne ist romantisch und gesagt haben wir
die hässlichen dinge also wirklich
kennen ja den höhen geführt
wenn man trotzdem gerade auch wenn wir
sind in berlin guckt man sich die
öffentlichen gebäude an wo ist denn die
ganze solarenergie wo ist denn das ganze
nach wie vor wir reden über erneuerbare
energien aber wo haben wir sie denn und
das finde ich so schade dass da auch in
der vergangenheit das überhaupt nicht
genutzt wurde soll wir müssen jetzt
einfach mal eins machen kommen gut ist
nicht grundlastfähig na also man hat
kein wind weht und wenn keine sonne
stand dann haben wir halt ein problem
sagte mazin ist kein problem wir wollen
das aber wollen fraktion aber eben
dieses jahr hatten wir sind ehrlich in
ganz europa und es ist mir können den
wind nicht produzieren wir können nicht
nach die sonne einschalten werden auch
im ausland nicht trauen zu halten
mussten kohlestrom aus polen und aus
tschechien herz
[Musik]